hey this is presh talwalkar
in the following diagram
if the red area between a square and its
inscribed circle
equals the blue area
between a smaller circle and its
inscribed square
what is the value of the large circle's
radius divided by the small circle's
radius
i want to thank yosi for suggesting a
problem that inspired this puzzle
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we'll get started by considering the red
and blue areas separately
let's first determine the red area
we'll draw the center of the circle and
the diameter of the circle which spans
two radii of the circle
the red area equals the area of the
large square minus the area of the large
circle
the large square has a side of two r
and therefore its area is its side
length squared which is the quantity two
r squared
the area of the large circle is pi r
squared
this simplifies to be 4r squared minus
pi r squared
which is then
r squared times the quantity 4 minus pi
so we've determined the red area
now let's determine the blue area in
terms of the smaller circle's radius
we'll do the same thing
from the center of the circle we'll draw
the diameter
that spans across the diagonal of the
square
this has a length of two little r
the diameter of the circle is equal to
the diagonal of the square
therefore the side length of the square
will be an isosceles right triangle
whose hypotenuse is 2r
the square's side length will be r times
the square root of two
the blue area equals the area of the
small circle minus the area of the small
square
this will be pi little r squared minus
the quantity little r times the square
root of 2 squared
this simplifies to be pi r squared minus
2r squared
which equals little r squared times the
quantity pi minus two
we now know the blue area and the red
area so we set these two areas equal to
each other
we then take this equation and divide
both sides by pi minus 4
and little r squared
this gives us the ratio of the radii
squared
and we then take the square root of each
side to get that the large circle's
radius divided by the small circle's
radius is equal to the square root of
the quantity pi minus 2
all over 4 minus pi
and this is approximately 1.153
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
if you like this video you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can also support me
on patreon
you can also follow me on social media
either at mindyourdecisions or at
preshtalwalker depending on the site